at a small Health Center on the
outskirts of cameroon's capital yunde a
historic moment in the fight against
malaria a small serum that can save from
the deadly parasite is being
administered for the first time to Baby
Daniela Millions have died of malaria
most are African
children these nurses and doctors have
seen parents helpless in the face of
their children suffering watching them
unable to breathe in distress with a
high fever eventually leading to an
agonized ing death now they can save
lives thanks to the new antimalaria
vaccine program being rolled out by
cameroon's Health
Services we are a district with a fairly
High prevalence it should also be
remembered that the vaccine complements
existing measures including impregnated
mosquito Nets and environmental
sanitation Cameroon is offering the rtss
antimalaria vaccine free of charge to
all infants up to the age of 6mth old it
took 50 years of scientific research to
develop the vaccine the challenge has
been the mutating nature of the malaria
parasite part of the Breakthrough came
from a tree found in Chile its substance
strengthens intensity of the immune
response in the
vaccine it is a disease that is very
difficult because it is transmitted by a
parasite with a life cycle that's very
complicated we have a vaccine which has
demonstrated Effectiveness and safety we
have really studied and tested it to be
sure there's no side effects that would
cause problems following the covid
pandemic unfounded fear of the new
malaria vaccine seems to be spreading
faster than its actual benefits the
challenge for health workers is to
convince parents like Ella that the new
vaccine is safe for their
children if it was talked about
everywhere maybe in the media or in
communities and people are informed then
I would be more prepared to vaccinate
right now I feel a little uncomfortable
and unsure the UN says that every 2
minutes a child dies of malaria with
this new vaccine roll out this is about
to change the small Serum is a big
victory in the fight against a parasite
offering the possibility of saving
millions of lives across the world
Nicholas Hawk Al
[Music]
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer